hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast application of targeted next
generation sequencing panels in
neurodevelopmental disorder research I
am Kristin correct and heal of lab roots
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots for more information please visit
lab recom this event is sponsored by
thermo Fisher Scientific iron Ion
Torrent
next-generation sequencing utilizes
massively parallel sequencing to
generate thousands of mega bases of
sequence information per day opening
doors to new research studies that were
once difficult to accomplish in a
practical manner powered by
semiconductor chips Ion Torrent
sequencing technology is simpler faster
and more cost effective and scalable
than other benchtop next-generation
sequencing technologies we have a few
important announcements before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as you
can and any questions we do not address
today will be answered via email you can
enlarge the slide window by clicking on
the screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window and if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button in the lower left this is an
educational webinar webinar and best
offers free continuing education credit
after the webinar is over please click
on the CD button located in the bottom
left-hand corner of your webpage and
follow the process of obtaining your
credits I would now like to introduce
today's speakers Alessandra Musa and
Francisco Hernandez Guzman
dr. Alessandra Musa is a director of
laboratory of molecular genetics of
neuro development department department
an associate professor of pediatrics at
department of neurosciences and
department of women's and child health
at university of padova
dr. musha's areas of interest include
neurodevelopmental disorders
intellectual disability and autism
spectrum disorders early onset epilepsy
and hereditary deafness Francisco
Hernandez Guzman is a senior product
manager for the clinical sequencing
decision at Thermo Fisher Scientific he
manages the ions ampliseq
custom product line including the
automated custom design creation process
in ion ampliseq designer and custom
design services Francisco has been
working in the life sciences field for
20 years and has been a product manager
for the past seven years now I will now
turn it over to dr. Musa for her
presentation oh hello everyone
so we will talk today about the
application or targeted next-generation
sequencing panels in neurodevelopmental
disorder research as I was presented I
would just go ahead and say that we are
working at the University Children's
Hospital in Padua we are clinically part
of the neuroscience section of our
department and the laboratory is set in
a different building as you can see it
here and the laboratory mice genetically
development is in the pediatric research
building this is our setting and I guess
what I want to say is we are
pediatricians involved in neuro
development we are our scientific
interest is focused on this so we
started genetic basis of conditions
involving intellectual disability autism
spectrum disorder early epilepsy of
various types and sensory neural hearing
loss we in the course of the years have
developed and are currently working with
for Angie
panels to new ones addressing cortical
brain malformations and cerebral palsy
are in progress what our
neurodevelopmental disorders this is
this is the definition of a group of
conditions that are clinically an
ideologically highly heterogeneous and
are characterized by a wide range of
overlapping clinical features common
features may include and alleged
disability autism spectrum disorder
speech difficulties on neurodevelopment
reservations in general seizure
microcephaly ataxia impaired sleep and
neuro are radiological correlate this
all these things are common or may be
common to different conditions so the
diagnosis based on exclusive clinical
criteria may be very difficult or just
simply not possible and on the other
hand a theological information are
highly needed to provide insight into
the pathogenic mechanisms of these
conditions and help understanding the
different phenotypes and among the
different phenotypes the variable
clinical expression which is very high
so with this in mind how many possible
genes are involved this is the question
how many disease genes should be
investigated if we wanted to cover the
etiologies of this condition up until
very recent lower apathy recently I
should say this these questions of the
possibility of answering these questions
was hampered by technology and they're
now and it's now possible to find the
right answer with next-generation
sequencing technologies but then then
the question is so which technology are
we choosing which is the possible NGS
strategies and how do we decide which
strategy we want to use so the two
possible options are the two main
options in our whole exome sequencing
and targeted gene panels the first one
within the first one is a primary option
for cases with unusual phenotypes penis
after would likely not be resolved by
analysis of known disease genes or in
which it is not possible to hypothesize
obvious it's theologies phenotypes that
have no good targeted panels that seem
to give a reasonably high yield answer
on the other hand targeted gene panels
we think this is definitely the strategy
of choice in conditions in which a known
cohort of disease or candidate genes can
actually give a good detection rate
which is obviously which is becoming
obvious but is in particular a case for
hearing loss and importing the
Federation to actually come up with the
strategy is the analytical performance
of excellence versus panels so in if we
consider targeted gene panels we can say
that with this strategy a much lower
percentage of excellent getting
sufficient coverage we want our
sequences to be covered as best as we
can so the width of coverage and the
death of coverage the depth of coverage
may significantly impact on the ability
to detect genetic alteration on the
other hand if it's true that extend and
baffle coverage are critical elements of
a good analytical performance then we
have to also recognize that whole exomes
are actually not really whole and in
fact there are recent reports that have
been published in 2014 and 2017 that
indicates that in individual study for
the identification of the etiology of
rare Mendelian disorders whole exome
sequencing the detected about 30% had a
detection rate at about 30% so this this
is what we have to
start with so in our setting we decided
that opted for a targeted strategy which
was the Ion Torrent NGS platform why did
we made this choice what is the reason
what are the reasons of our choice well
first of all the Ion Torrent
NGS in our opinion offers innovation
within an innovative technology so it
was attractive for that reason the PGM
as a platform combines state-of-the-art
and GS sequencing with features the
respond to the needs of a single
laboratory and ours is not a
particularly large laboratory it's very
focused one our aim is to focus on
individual genes and on specific gene
regions we wanted the possibility of
obtaining a wider sequence coverage and
a very high battle coverage we wanted a
simple workflow and we wanted to have a
time to get resolved that could be short
and we do have results in a matter of
days and another consideration is the
throughput can be very high in a single
sequencing run which is in turn a more
cost-effective system these are our
these are our reasons but so we find
ourselves into targeted panels and
there's a big offer in the market the
market offers a lot there are many
companies offering panels over of all
sorts and and kind sir why would any
want to choose a customized panel why
would you why would you want to test
customize something that's already made
well for a series of reasons I guess our
aim at disease focus panels the fact
that we have a very specific involvement
in disease areas and and this is coupled
with our capacity of a complete
phenotypic
accusations in these disease areas for
the test cases our goal of studying the
pathogenic role of this is causing and
let's say established candidate genes
and their molecular pathogenesis when
the need of sequencing at the high depth
and repeating it but I think it's very
important not just because we have we
are more confident that we detect
variants with a high depth of coverage
but also because we may find yourself in
the condition of dealing with for
example somatic diseases which is a
problem even in Mendelian disorders that
actually is becoming more and more
obvious and the need of including
analysis of specific genomic regions of
interest among these regions some
possibly residing outside the coding
sequences so but that wouldn't be
obviously included then we made a choice
of avoiding unsolicited result or
incidental findings so we want to choose
what we're dealing with and then the aim
of generating translational immediately
actionable data the process of
developing so what we think is the most
appropriate tool is arm is a rather
complicated as it's a rather
time-consuming and it's it's it's a good
job to do so we think the starting point
is a specific biological and clinical
knowledge of the problem and the
possibility of a complete phenotypic
characterization this is the foundation
of our work on which then we add an
extensive literature search an extensive
data mining process to get out all the
possible information about the genes and
other conditions about the relationships
and then gene prioritization we just say
evaluating a
and a wide array of different evidences
going from gene expression to function
and Nappers to Olmec data with a great
deal of manual curation and I guess I
I'd say this is if not the major one of
the most important steps in the process
let me give you an idea what we've done
in the choice of our panel and what are
the criteria we started with like for
example our epileptic panel we chose
gene we chose genes from what's
available from the growing list of genes
that are available in the literature
which has 31 genes I guess it's fair to
say that this was a panel that we have
developed in two years three years ago
now in 2014 with the empty set designer
3.6 version we selected 31 genes genes
associated with early answered epileptic
allopathy or epilepsy with onset within
the first year of life and we found
herself with the clinical clustering of
genes including dravet syndrome genes
infantile spasms epilepsy of infancy
different type of clinical pictures that
would all be involved in that would all
be included in conditions within the
first year of life among these genes 15
genes were underlined autosomal dominant
conditions 90s autosomal recessive there
were some x-linked genes it was a panel
of 773 applicants with a coverage of
about 98% but the concept to you is
early onset this is the selection we
know now that we have to expand this
gene this panel a great deal but we've
had very good result with this
our hearing loss panel was chosen based
on non syndromic criteria we wanted a
panel for non syndromic sensory neural
hearing loss and we chose to we chose
this because this is the type of hearing
loss that present more difficulties in
the differential diagnosis and we came
up with the final subset of 59 genes
that represent in 65 percent of known
deafness genes but about 90% of the
deafness mutation that had been reported
in no syndromic restaura nor hearing
loss so that was very efficient we
selected genes strictly associated with
non syndromic hearing loss genes
frequently mutated in in literature and
public databases in caucasian which is
the type of population we mainly have to
deal with we didn't include genes with
only private mutation report or genes
who which function was not strictly ear
related but in the clinical clustering
as I point out here you can see we have
eleven Usher syndrome genes so why do we
have announced in trauma hearing loss
panel with Usher syndrome genes because
we have to deal with a young population
mainly with pediatrician and we have to
know that there are conditions which
onset is apparently seemingly non
syndromic hearing loss so this is one of
the reason why we have to exactly know
what we're doing because if we didn't
include these genes
even though these are syndromic we would
lose part of what is seemingly known
syndromic early on so that was that was
our that was our point a third panel and
I will end with this is a comorbidity
panel yet another criteria we wanted to
intercept genes that were the cause of a
coma
with a clinical picture between
intellectual disability and autism
spectrum disorders so we started out
with 4,000 genes involved with autism
spectrum disorder or intellectual
disability gather from data base and
literature then we filtered by
recurrence clinical phenotype gene
functions and pathway and came up with
about 1,000 genes of which we then
select the very strictly genes that were
shared between the two areas and could
be used for protein protein interaction
construction we then added some direct
interactor and/or very frequent genes
and then with a great deal of manual
curation we made this we we finally got
to the to go to the panel with the
concept of the expected informative
yield we ended up with a final subset of
74 genes which functional clustering
included target of the fragile X mental
reservation protein postsynaptic
proteins chromatin modifiers and eight
hub gene interactors and most of these
we're autosomal dominant genes
responsible of autosomal dominant
condition xx we're involved with
x-linked mental retardation some of them
are autosomal recessive but I want what
I want to point out is that in this
panel we did include all the known genes
involved with the rat Endermen phenotype
which is a very important continuum in
which the comorbidity between
intellectual disability and autism
factor disorder is a main is a key
feature this is a larger applicant and
and again this is our comorbidity panel
so
it's a choice at a very specific choice
now but this is a lot of work what I
just represented is a lot of ways
another question was what if we could
use what if we had a large array of
carefully prioritized genes to
investigate specific clinical topics
what if we could access to something
that was already studied in order to
choose a gene we then could choose from
this sort of catalog and develop
comprehensive multigenic panels which is
what we finally want to do this is
something that we had in mind and we
were fortunate enough but we had the
opportunity of a of having an early
access to this new iron ampliseq
on-demand panel system so we were very
happy to try this new system and see how
it worked and we found ourselves
browsing disease areas that with an
intuitive and informative and friendly
interface that gave us the opportunity
of putting together a panel including
genes in our areas of choice I have to
say that the disease gene catalog was
somehow more limited than it is now and
will become in near future
so we came up with a 59 gene panel which
we arm which which was which included
about 1,800 amplicons
with the amplitude dimension of about
200 base pairs which we analyzed with
the chemistry that a new chemistry the
ion ampliseq library kid plus and the IM
PGM high q-- view OT toolkit on 316
sheets though data analysis was
initially done with the ion torrents
sweet software five point two point two
with a couple of plugins the variant
color and the coverage analysis and the
rest of the in silicon analysis was done
according to our current protocol so the
annotation the processing and
elaboration based on variant filtering
varying based on different criteria of
filtering so the coverage the minimum
allele frequency based on our in-house
database based on the use of a
combination of in silico prediction
tools and and we then normally finish
with Sanger validation and family
segregation analysis and this was done
for this experiment as well we have done
three main experiments and that we're
designed to study a new panel which we
didn't understand we which we didn't
know before so we based everything on
our previous experience and I won't go
into details but I am very happy to to
do it if there's interested about that
I guess though the main concept here is
we in all the experiment we had a very
good result in terms of poly clonality a
very good result in terms of low quality
a very good result in time in terms of
total review we obtained and a very good
result in terms of clustering of read
length which was actually better than
what we were used to having with our
custom amplified designer and the
previous chemistry so very good result
from this new system on top of the on
top of the very good and friendly
interface so the question here was
okay we we had a few numbers here we had
on target reads that were very good the
average which reads per amplicon the
coverage was 176 the amplicon with no
strand bias very high the the end to end
of of the applicants and the same thing
for the base coverage with which was
very high with no strand bias and end to
end reads this is a this is this is a
profile of the coverage of our
applicants applicants that shows in all
of our experiments the fact that we have
a very low percentage of uncover
applicant or not enough cover applicants
with a coverage less than 20% which is
the 20x I'm sorry which is our cutoff
and these low coverage was predictably
of in regions with a high content of CG
or regions that are known for being
difficult to sequence so we would expect
lower coverage in this region so we
didn't have any surprise of low coverage
in our panel the overall average
variance detection the average variants
per library was about 238 and the total
variant we found was about 770 with
about 200 private variants of which very
few with an insufficient coverage and
none of them was a frameshift deletion
insertion that gives us the idea of a
very little likelihood of errors here so
if it's only a few uncovered variants we
normally chase that too we have a very
good coverage of the private variants
generally speaking and so these are in
our opinion very good result and very
consistent ones now we wonder what are
we looking at why are we getting this
good result is the on demand panel or is
it the new chemistry that's involved in
it so if we look at our experiment and
we want to figure out and we want to try
and answer this question we can compare
this result to what we had before with
our custom ampliseq and the amplifier
kit and the ampliseq library kit that we
used before so what we did was we try
another experiment with our custom
implicit designer and with the new
chemistry and this is what we obtained
so obviously the UM basic library kit so
the chemistry with which we now analyze
we now process our panel is obviously
very good and is obviously a key element
in the good results we obtain if you
compare this to result it's obvious that
the chemistry make a definite difference
if we compare the result we have on the
ampliseq library kit plus and the
ampliseq library that we used before on
the same panel we see that all of the
important elements we want to consider
so the percent of on target the
end-to-end amplicon reading the
end-to-end reads on base coverage are
all higher than what we used to obtain
before which was not a bad result but
this is a lot better so I think we have
answered the question which one is
the most important or what is very
important in this experiment so in our
view how do we how do we consider the
system in general we think that we had a
greatly improved interface and which was
very important it's a user friendly and
gives us a readily available display of
information which is fundamental for the
process of choosing as I said the right
tool there is a large and I believe
growing curated inventory of genes that
recognizes pathogenic and evolving major
human genetic conditions that we can
then we can use and this is this is a
big part of the work that we used to do
before
this is amal's viewing gene maps and
expect the coverage so we know what to
expect from experiments which is a very
important information we didn't use that
the genes organized in different areas
of pathology and this provides essential
information about each gene and
associated phenotypes and it's important
to have them classified hierarchically
into categories already the repository
genes can be arranged in any combination
and this is very important so they can
be analyzed in panels of a wide range of
sizes the system provides high
flexibility both in terms of content and
possible integration and especially the
possibility of building comprehensive
targeted panel which is which is our
goal and the wet analysis procedures are
absolutely optimized so the key element
the gene prioritization is a work that
we find done already so this is a big
part of what we used to do and it's
fundamental health the interface is
but again it's fully informative and
that's important the genes can be
assembled with the high flexibility into
panels of different compositions and
different sizes and the chemistry of the
new system is definitely a big
improvement in the workflow so at the
end of the story I think we have we hit
the target we are not chasing a moving
target or at least it's not as moving as
it used to be before we have the
possibility of assembling comprehensive
disease panels with great flexibility
within content and timing because we can
decide of modifying our panel whatever
we want and however we decide and with
this I thank you of your attention and
I'm happy to answer questions thank you
very much thank you very much dr. Musa
for that informative presentation next
dr. Hernandez Guzman will provide a live
demonstration of designing a custom gene
panel using ion ampliseq designer but
before I turn it over to him I would
like to remind our audience that we have
a couple of full questions that we would
like for them to answer and so if you
could take just a quick moment to do
that and then we will move on to dr.
Hernandez Guzman
all right thank you and now I would like
to turn it over to dr. Hernandez Guzman
for his presentation great q can you
please just kindly confirm that you can
see my screen okay I think hopefully you
can see my screen okay so what I'm what
I'm going to focus today is really
getting a little bit more hands-on with
the whole process of creating a panel
and as the Primeau here I mentioned we
are using a website called implicit comm
and when you first visit the site this
way you'll see if you're currently a
user then you'll be able to just sign in
if you're not a current user then you
just click on the register new account
and it only takes a couple of minutes to
register an account just try to provide
your information and then you'll be able
to access the website once you've
accessed the website what you can see is
the website is organized in three
different sections it's organized and
ready to use panels these are typically
six panels that column in small reaction
packs and they're organized between DNA
and RNA and these are really panels that
have been in our inventory for a while
and people have been using them fairly
successfully on the right out of the
screen is what we like to call the
made-to-order panels and dr. more here
in a her experience as she used some of
these panels in her earlier studies
which she was able to do quite
successfully and this is really a very
flexible tool that allows you to go not
only from a gene level to regional level
and offers you different amplicon sizes
for different applications it's
extremely flexible but what you do see
is that you're tied to a mate order
process which basically means that
whenever you create a design the design
needs to be actually computed in the
backend and that can take some time and
then it has to be manufactured from
scratch so that can also take some time
so there's some advantages and
disadvantages to to use the mid-to order
versus our new product that we have
today which is really much more focus as
an on-demand panel meaning you can
create this design immediately the
content is available in inventory it can
be pulled together rather quickly and
also you have other key benefits such as
you have small reaction from our packs
the performance has been optimized and
you can actually get a preview of the
performance that you could expect in the
lab this is something that you don't
typically get with a made-to-order panel
with the on-demand panels you actually
get a preview of how likely it is the
panel to perform the on-demand panels
are focused on human and the human
genome and is really more related to
human disease research analysis there's
two entry points that you'll be able to
get access to is if you already have a
list of targets that you're interested
in then you can just proceed to the list
let me just kind of preview that for a
second here you can start typing in your
your gene names or you can choose a file
where you can just input a series of
gene lists in a batch in a batch form
however what our focus in today's
demonstration is going to be really
using the disease research areas because
we find that this is basically content
that has been organized by gene
associations to different diseases that
have been studied by various public
databases so when I click on the disease
research two areas here what you'll find
is a pop organizational model here where
everything is organized basically in
alphabetical order and you have many
different sort of high level
organizational diseases so for example
if you're interested in cardiovascular
diseases you can just click on
cardiovascular it goes down into maybe
they say I'm interested in heart
diseases I come down to that and maybe I
can still say I'm interested in heart
earlier I can go down to that level and
then select sort of subcategories within
those just those areas
I can always kind of go back to the
initial sort of high level
organizational and then at this point
let's say that I am interested in some
of the heart disease is and maybe I'm
interested in let's say the heart
failure that we talked about and maybe I
can have also deceased are related to
heart valve conditions so I can select
those as well right now what the tool is
doing is basically storing that
selection at this level you will notice
that there is actually a limit as to how
many genes you can actually expect and
there is a maximum of 500 genes that we
can accept although when you go ahead
and order we can actually create such a
large panel of the 300 genes which is
really really large at this point but
when you start in your selection
exercise this is the way you would go
ahead and do it so at this point let's
say that I'm I'm ready to create my
first panel so this is webinar and then
I said this is panel number one what you
can do is just click the proceed button
and what it's going to happen now is the
tool is going to assess the content of
those genes and then it's going to go
ahead and do a search of what is
currently available on demand and
separate the content that is not
available on demand for you the content
that is available on demand is the
content that is been available in
inventory and also there's performance
metrics associated to it so for example
let's say that I'm interested in the the
raspbian right here what you notice here
at the bottom there's a track called
expected coverage and in the expected
coverage track what I can do is I can
start zooming in to really get a better
understanding of my region so for
example let's say I have a variant in
this particular exon I can zoom in there
and try to figure out okay what is my
expected coverage level in terms of
number of reads or the depth and I can
see okay well everything is covered
nicely
can proceed with with my design
if I click on a different gene then the
the igv viewer that has been integrated
into our tool updates automatically
there's also a gene information table
the scores also meta table right here
and you can also have other useful links
to other publicly available website as
well as an interesting point here of
what is this gene associated with as far
as other diseases that might be
interesting for you to study
so just because I started with a
particular set of focus and let's say in
the cardiovascular disease space I can
notice that now I can this gene is also
involved in mental disorders so these
associations are actually more of a
matrix type of associations they're not
just necessarily linear based so a
single gene can be associated with
multiple diseases which is a very
interesting I think to to learn so at
this point users if you do see a
particular panel that you are you happy
with this is a 61 gene panel but let's
say that you're missing a gene let's say
I want to include for whatever reason I
want to include a tumor suppressor here
just as an example in this case it tells
you you know it's very basically smart
enough to tell you that that tumor
suppressor is already included in your
list so then life is okay under say you
want to include a different one let's
say I put the infamous back of one gene
what it will do is actually add it to my
list and it will just label it here with
a little dot to just say hey I added
this after my initial selection so it's
easy for somebody to say okay this is my
my first selection that I've created and
then I have my additional content that I
created you will notice that there is a
set of genes that are not available in
our inventory at this time and as dr.
mahir mentioned our inventory is growing
so you could expect regular updates
throughout the year where you have
additional content being added so maybe
today I may have for example the Ellen
jeanny not available in inventory I
believe in a few months from now the
same gene may now be part of our
available on-demand inventory so I would
encourage you if you start creating
designs
you know whenever we have a new release
of the software you may want to look
back and see ok somewhere back on - now
I can get available on demand now when
you have the content that is available
on demand then it's very easy for for
you to just perceive because this this
particular design that has this
experimental data information available
for you is basically ready to order
there's really no creation of the design
even though the download results
function is disabled at this time the
design is ready to go so you can just
click the order button and here you will
have the option for doing a manual
workflow or if you have an eye of
instrument you can also select that and
that updates the library kit that you
want this is actually optional you don't
have to include it in your order if you
do it gets processed with the order once
you click to the order button here what
this is going to do is going to move you
to the pre card option here where you
then have other options let's say you're
interested in adding additional let's
say for the s5 you might want to add
some chips one to your order and then
you can proceed to the card so but let's
go back here because one of the very
important questions that often happens
is ok you have this nice organizational
and actually if I look at it as a table
view you can see that for example my
elastin and geney's is quite important
for my because this is actually based on
Association score this is quite
important for my particular gene so
let's say that I do want to include that
gene as part of my overall design and
maybe another gene over here just
general transcription factor here I can
go back to my grid and you'll notice
that this genes are actually being
selected here what happens is that what
we've put together is because we knew
that the
we'll be certain genes that will be
important for you that may not be
necessarily beyond our inventory right
off the bat you will see that there is
an option here for creating what we like
to call a spiking panel and what the
spiking panel is going to do is going to
leverage our made-to-order process for
creating this design and when you're
ready to order this particular design it
will be ordered in a concentration that
is compatible with spike in and what
that means is that the original panel
when you go back to your lab and you
have to your two full panel as you'll be
able to spike in this panel to add
effectively coverage for this additional
two genes from the invite informatics
side all the bad files will be updated
everything will be ready to go when you
run a spike in panel so from an analysis
standpoint you don't have to worry about
it either but this is a very nice way
for us to be able to offer as much
flexible content as we can without
making any sacrifices as far as having
to wait till the content is available
than inventory so so it's actually a
quite an exciting experience here so
once you click the order button then
this design will be locked which means
that all the files get created for
analysis if you do want to go back and
make modifications to that initial lock
design we have a very nice feature here
called the clone panel what this is
going to do is basically going to copy
everything that you have in your initial
design and they basically open it up
again so that you can edit that
particular design so at this point I
think that I've given a fairly nice
demonstration here of how easy it is to
create this on-demand panels the last
bit that I wanted to call out is the
videos that we have available there is
multiple videos of one is right here for
just getting started
there is videos that is more specific to
working with the business research area
content there's also a short video also
for the gene list we've actually in
answer help if you go back into the
frequently asked questions you can see
that there is a series of questions
specifically targeting the on demand on
demand product so that you can go back
and maybe if you if you have some
questions that you want to see if
there's an answer for then you can go
quickly there and try to find more of a
self-service type of experience so with
that I think I like to open it up for
questions at this time
thank you very much thank you very much
dr. her name is Guzman and thank you
both for that informative presentation
before we get started on the question
and answer session I would like to just
remind our audience how to submit
questions you can submit your questions
by typing them in the Q&A box which can
be found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can
just a reminder that any questions we do
not have time for today will be answered
via email it's going to be for dr.
Hernandez Guzman after you customize a
panel what are the typical reaction
sizes you will get yes so if you're
working with the on demand product if
you're using a manual workflow you
basically get 24 reactions and the price
it will be according to those number of
reactions so it would be fairly
accessible if you are using an Iron Chef
type of protocol then you will get an a
reaction size offering these are the
reaction sizes that in the future we're
looking to expand so that people have a
little bit more choice but for the on
demand is basically two options for four
reaction sizes depending on whether
you're using a manual workflow or an
automated workflow okay thank you our
next question is for Alessandra what are
the top features of the Ion Torrent
systems
[Music]
well I guess I guess I insisted on that
in my presentation but I guess in
generally speaking the Ion Torrent
system is tailored to the need of a
single lab and is the answer to whoever
have need of doing next-generation
sequencing in that I clinically related
in a clinical research situation where
but that I need to be translatable and
actionable immediately the
next-generation sequencing of the
Ironton is innovative and is more
sustainable in my opinion than others
the characteristics of the new systems
are finally those the will allow to have
flexibility in choosing targeted panels
which is what we we were sort of
expecting because to work with panel
very often is to work with something
that we keep chasing with with a with a
with a situation that keeps moving so we
need to be flexible and we need to be
able to adapt this flexibility to our
experiment if I want to expand my panel
because there's a new gene and I find
that a new gene in the repository I can
just add it and I can just add it at
different times which gives me um a
better option which gives me what I
really what I really need instead of a
closed system to work with panels is in
general working with the situation
where we have the confidence of being
able to cover a certain clinical
condition of being able to have the
feeling that a negative result is
actually negative and we are not
hopefully not losing information so I
think I think these are the main these
are the key factor flexibility
confidence of having the possibility of
covering extensively
a clinical phenotype having the
possibility of having comprehensive
coverage I guess these are the main
features okay thank you our next
question is for dr. Hernandez Guzman how
many genes can I add to a spike in panel
oh yes that is actually a great question
and thank you for bringing this up so
the the maximum number of genes is
actually the metric that we use is
number of amplicons I can be added to a
spiking panel we're spiking a reaction
in this case it's actually a hundred and
twenty-three amplicons
per upper pool so that's a total of 246
amplicons for the two pools and what
that really translates to is
approximately around 10 to 12 genes it's
kind of hard to give a hard metric
because obviously not all genes are of
the same size so some require more
amplicons than others so really the
metric here to look for is a large
number of amplicons
that you can have but on average is
anywhere between 10 to 12 genes could be
added as a spiking reaction great thank
you
the next question goes to Alessandra
what are some factors young to consider
when choosing targeted panels other than
what you already shared
well I guess one of the most important
things now is to address the problem of
that coverage for two particular
conditions and one is somatic mosaicism
and one is probably a gene dosage we
know we know that gene dosage has always
been a problem so we cannot address gene
does it with we with sequencing but
next-generation sequencing has a
capacity of being reading with enough
that that we are getting there now what
we didn't expect or we didn't expect at
this at this extension is that we had to
deal with somatic mosaicism and it's
becoming more and more clear that even
with Mendelian disorder this is a
problem we have to address so we are we
have to have the feeling of having the
possibility of detecting variants with a
high confidence but we also want to be
able to detect various might be the
might have a different representation
but then the classical allelic one so I
guess I guess for this reason for this
two problems for a problem of death for
coverage in these two conditions there
isn't any other option than going with
panels that can give us an extremely
high coverage and an extremely extensive
coverage of the of the sequences we want
to analyze okay thank you
our next question goes to dr. Hernandez
Guzman is there any information provided
to make sure that the panel I'm
designing will have enough coverage yes
so this goes back to the view that I
showcased during the demonstration which
is really looking at the RGB viewer
there is that track called expected
coverage and what that track means is
basically
that for for those genes that have that
information we ran them in the lab and
we observed a particular sort of
performance metric and we reported that
in that particular track so when you're
when you're looking at making sure that
you have enough coverage it's not only
about sort of making sure that the the
exome region is covered by the amplicon
but it's also understanding how well
that is covered so the the actual sort
of overall coverage metric which is not
to be confused between in silico
coverage versus expected coverage those
two factors are a little bit you know
how a tendency to get confused but we
report both we actually reporter in
silico coverage which is how well were
we able to put our primers in such a way
that the amplicon coverage the whole
exotic region or the the c.d.s regions
and then the expected coverage then is
okay what is it that we observed in the
lab so we we report both and those can
be accessible from the itv viewer as is
showcased in the demo thank you so much
that's all the time we have for
questions today I would like to thank
our sponsor Thermo Fisher Scientific en
torrent for making it possible to bring
this presentation to you today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through January of 2018 you will receive
an email from lab roots alerting you
when this webcast will be available for
replay we invite you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event we'll see
you next time goodbye